there's probably nothing I could talk
about anything somebody's doing step
back there don't worry about it we're
clearing the plates on my bucket list
is something I don't even know if I'm
ever gonna be able to do because of
geographical location I can't really be
in New York now I'm in LA for like two
jobs and I've always wanted to do
Broadway so that's been nothing on my
bucket list maybe when I'm older I guess
but yeah I love I love musical theaters
oh my god theaters all the theaters
sometimes I call him
Chevy Chase from the European vacation
you know all those men cuz he's you know
Chevie choice just goes big like all the
time like the lights like all that he
does that with like fireworks
he's so Texan he's a Texas dad Brandon
Brando Oh sometimes I stay I mean no I
don't I say that with every other I
don't know I don't think we need why
don't have anything since we not love
each other stud I like you don't have a
nickname for me either do you oh my gosh
he does not he just made that up we were
gonna have nicknames we'll be back to
you he's just really good at like
teaching stuff my favorite thing that
was Seth was like six years old and they
were gonna do a model car like build a
model car you gonna like Hobby Lobby or
whatever and or Michaels in her cuz
stuff would touch something it screwed
up cuz he's six I was like hey y'all you
enjoying that because why haven't really
done I think every mom feels like a
failure sometimes not all the time but a
lot of times like you just you know you
look first of all I'm like how is it a
shock that it's bedtime
like bedtimes every night like why are
we constantly man argument about how you
don't wanna go night-night like it's a
thing that happens every day this isn't
a surprise and then the argument is so
fun no that's where I feel a little bit
like failure and with food to our two
boys are
picky with food and I'm just like -
you're gonna starve I think the best
I've ever felt as a parent is hearing
from like the school that our little
girl was really kind like someone was
crying there it was like a
parent-teacher thing and they told us
she was like the most kind and always
made sure everybody's feeling good and
and get left out and she's just really
sweet and I was like Furby half of me
was like super excited and proud and
then half of me was pissed because I'm
like why isn't she like not at home she
can be so mean at home but that's every
kid